♪♪
-I often say in the body
of "Corrections"
that I stand corrected.
I've been told
I should say, "I sit corrected."
Because I never stand
on this show.
I, of course, used to stand
when we started this show,
but I had to stop when --
there's no easy way
to say this --
everybody was
a real dick about it.
The vice president lives
at the Naval Observatory,
not The White House,
which is something
I'm pretty sure Obama
had to tell Biden every day.
[ As Obama ] Shouldn't you be,
uh, getting home?
[ Normal voice ] We did
a "Surprise Inspection"
of our writers,
the segment on our show
where we read some of
the bad jokes they submitted.
Matt Goldich
wrote a joke about Pepsi
no longer producing Sierra Mist
and how that was sad because it
was the main ingredient
in Sierra Mistu.
This was the art card for that.
And then people said,
"In Sierra Mist,
the bottle is green,
not the drink."
And that is the only problem
with that joke.
There was also a joke
about the show "Wednesday."
The punch line was,
"Here's The Thing..."
And then we showed a picture
of the character Thing.
That joke worked,
got a proper applause break.
Now, I'm not sure if people
actually liked the joke
or if it was just so good
compared to what was around it.
You know, if you're
in the desert long enough,
you'll drink your own piss.
It doesn't mean it's refreshing.
There's a reason
Pepsi stopped producing it.
But whatever reason,
be it the quality
or the surroundings,
people did genuinely
like that joke.
I will concede the point.
And multiple people then,
in turn, made this point.
And now I'm quoting someone.
They said,
"You didn't say who wrote --"
Because we do call out
the writers
after their
"Surprise Inspection."
"You didn't say who wrote
the 'Wednesday' Thing joke.
You do this all the time.
When the joke gets a laugh,
you move on without saying
the writer's name."
That's true.
We made a joke
that the Mars candy corporation
should have been inspired by
current events and created
a new mascot, a gray M&M,
who carries around
classified documents.
I forgot. You guys, I forgot.
1997, there was a gray M&M.
There was a whole
marketing event created by
M&M with the imposter M&M,
who was gray,
and if you found a gray M&M,
you'd get $1 million.
Now, I know some people
who found him,
and they did not turn it in
for $1 million,
because -- I don't know
what it was.
I don't know
if it was the gray dye
they used or what.
Because the high
when you took one of those
was out of this world.
You remember '97, Shoemaker?
Poppin' grays?
I mean...
We'd be listening to The Verve
or The Verve Pipe.
What a time.
What a time for Verve bands.
'90s. It was a cornucopia
of bands with Verve
in the title.
And we had Korn.
For the life of me,
I cannot remember.
What made me think
that we were wise
and we'd never compromise?
Tell you this, though.
Married now, three kids,
bills to pay.
If I get a gray M&M now,
I turn it in for the money.
I got called out
on a mispronunciation again,
which is bad,
because I've already
gotten in enough trouble
with the knitting community.
I said this was
someone holding an
"I Love Wally" mug
at crotch level.
It's pronounced "croch."
We mentioned Sir Isaac Newton.
I said he would ignore -- He was
so into the idea of gravity,
he would ignore it if a
naked lady fell into his lap.
A lot of you said
he probably would ignore it.
It is speculated
that he died a virgin
because he thought --
One person --
Only one person said this.
I didn't do any digging.
I don't find
the guy that interesting.
That he was a virgin
because he thought
that would give him immortality.
And, in a way, you know what?
He's right.
Because here we are.
Obviously, he died.
Still talking about him,
still saying his name.
God bless him.
While all
his other friends were,
to use the parlance of the time,
out chasin' tail,
he knew to be
sitting in a field,
watching --
in an orchard or whatever --
just making sure he was
the guy who was there
when the apple came down.
We talked about my mistake
two weeks back
referring to the
Reillys as the O'Reillys.
There was an incident
I did not mention last week
because I had been advised by
my legal team
to let it play out...
in the courts.
So, after I made the mistake --
incorrectly referred
to the Reillys
as the O'Reillys, I found this
in my dressing room.
Not by itself -- with this.
And you know what I did?
Went to H.R. immediate--
right away, reported it,
which is what they told us
to do this week...
in our Respect in the Workplace
seminar.
And if that doesn't
sound familiar,
Wally, it's because they said it
in the first 15 minutes.
You -- I wish you could
all see Wally roll into
an all-staff meeting dead last,
not a care in the world,
sunglasses inside.
Just sits down, all his bags.
Wally don't need no preamble.
You know what you are good at,
though, Wally?
Scanning in the QR code.
Point is, i call H.R., say,
"I got this threatening note
in my dressing room."
And they say, you know,
"Do you have proof it's,
you know,
it's one of the Reillys?"
And I'm like, "Who else
would leave it there?"
And they were like, "Without
proof, we can't do anything."
And I'm like, "Who's going to
stand up to this
reign of terror, you know?"
And then she says something,
the H.R. person.
Always very nice,
until this thing.
She goes, "I'm gonna tell
you something.
If you ever repeat it,
I'm going to
disavow I ever said it.
Let it go.
It's not worth it.
Let it go."
And I'm not saying
she's a Reilly,
but when I said, "I'm going
to kick it up the ladder,"
she called me in "eedgit."
I've been complaining about
people misusing our P.O. Box
to send Mac Tonight
merchandise and crafts.
I'm happy to report
this has slowed down.
I received a very cool gift
from a jackal
with the request that I show it
first and then read the note.
This is really very cool.
Take a look.
And I'm guessing,
because a jackal sent it,
I think I can guess what it is.
"Dear, Seth, your dog Frisbee
is with the angels now.
Not. It's a skull that...
Someone named Mason.
Thank you, Mason.
Said they got it -- Poached it?
Got it. No.
It's a black-backed-jackal
skull.
And this is cool.
It has -- The tape
is actually there for a reason.
I guess even after
a jackal dies,
they don't stop [bleep] yapping.
Someone also wrote --
Because I would think
this would, like, pair very well
with everything out here,
but I guess someone just wrote a
very simple note that said,
"You have too much [bleep]
on your desk."
It might be time to
thin that out.
Oh, I sang a few lines
from "Bad, Bad Leroy Brown."
Some people were
unfamiliar with the song,
asked who
the original singer was.
"Jim Crotch."
Croce?
The Clapper uses two claps,
not one.
Did a thing where
Mike Pence was running,
and the lights would go off
every time he clapped
and then back on.
It's two claps, not one.
Bunch of you knew that.
And it's just weird
how many of the 20-somethings
who I assume make up
the lion's share of our
audience would know that.
I read the comments from the
previous week's "Corrections,"
newest first.
So I'm going in reverse order.
And we told -- made a prop joke
about Amelia Earhart.
And, so, I read a comment
from someone that said,
"Thank you for the prop joke.
I might be, but I hope not,
the only pilot who watches
'Corrections.'"
The very next one I read,
which would have been
the previous comment --
Same person.
Their previous comment before
the one I just read you was,
"I honestly don't know why
I watch this."
That must have been
so amazing for you.
So upset that you
leave a comment,
and just seconds later,
I make a joke specific
to your profession.
What a day.
We made a lot of flubs regarding
the animal kingdom this week...
which means it's time
for our brand-new segment,
"Animal Flubs."
♪ Animal flubs, animal flubs ♪
♪ It's time to take a look
at some animal flubs ♪
♪ From the birds to the bees
to the baby bear cubs ♪
♪ It's time for animal flubs ♪
♪ And I know
you don't need to say
"baby" before
you say "bear cub" ♪
♪ Because in that case,
cub means baby ♪
♪ But when you're writing a song
on a Thursday afternoon
when you really should be
working on "A Closer Look" ♪
♪ Sometimes, your guy
might cut a few corners
in order to make
the rhyme scheme work ♪
♪ Animal flubs, animal flubs ♪
♪ I hope you're all ready
for some animal flubs ♪
♪ Call all your
pals, buddies, and buds ♪
♪ It's time for animal flubs ♪
♪ Are the five letters ♪
♪ You use ♪
♪ To spell "flubs" ♪
♪ Animal flubs ♪
You're right --
a cappella was better.
We mentioned beef prices rising,
but we showed a picture
of a dairy cow.
That's an animal flub.
This is an
African pygmy hedgehog,
the one we
commonly have as pets.
A European hedgehog
would be brown all over
without any white.
But they're both delicious.
We did a joke about a bird
getting in the house,
and we were told
the Photoshop here --
the size ratio is way off.
This Eurasian tree sparrow
got way scaled up.
That's an animal flub.
Trump mentioned
you'd go to jail
for five years
if you killed a bald eagle.
But someone said
that was only true when
bald eagles were endangered.
And due
to conservation efforts,
they've been making a comeback.
So bad time to be a bald eagle
with gambling debts.
Koalas -- Oh, we had a joke.
Here's the art card we used.
There was a radioactive capsule
went missing in Australia,
and we said,
"We think we found it."
And someone pointed out
that the capsule
was found in Western Australia,
where there are no koalas.
Bad animal flub.
They said
we should have used a quokka.
I had no idea what a quokka was.
I was a little afraid to look,
because Australia has some
weird-ass-looking animals,
but it was not that weird.
Let's take a look at
some video of a quokka.
[ Man screams ]
Seven days.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, this has been
"Animal Flubs."
♪ Animal flubs ♪
[ Gasps ]
[ Shudders ]
One second.
Can we get a single, Alex?
See me next week.
[ Laughter ]